[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome to the introductory
video of DevOps practitioner caused
Arthur by simpler in this video we'll
cover some interesting information about
widest services so innovative and useful
DevOps is the blending of the roles with
developers and operation support in
application service for example
developers write the code that is
deployed into application service
operations team maintain the application
server if the application fails to work
on deployment there is a knowledge gap
people with knowledge of both software
development and operations are required
to bridge this gap this is where DevOps
practitioners are required the software
development lifecycle is complex and has
a number of important phasing including
requirements gathering design software
development testing deployment and
production support traditionally these
faces have been performed by individuals
and teams who have very little
interaction with each other a key
divorce role is bridging the inter team
divides and improving communication
between phases deploying an updating
production application such as discrete
largely a manual task this is very
time-consuming and error-prone there are
now a wide range of tools allow these
tests be automated an important DevOps
is to make the best use of tools and
ensure that they are integrated to
achieve a high level of automation we
are already witnessing a sharp increase
in demand for DevOps engineer's around
the globe it may interest you to know
that developed engineers are in short
supply and companies are finding it
difficult to fill job vacancies as a
result there are many vacant dev office
jobs that need to be felt the median
salary for DevOps professionals
experience in one year or less is ninety
one thousand dollars this rises to one
hundred and thirty-five thousand dollars
for those with ten years or more
experience it is essential that IT
professionals update their knowledge in
this rapidly changing world in order to
improve their job prospects a working
environment with technical challenge of
DevOps is the need for the hour if you
are new to DevOps if you
assists office administrator or
developer or if you're responsible for
articulating the business benefits of
DevOps services is important to
understand best practices from their
benefits this will enable you to select
the perfect combination of software
tools to achieve highly automated
development and support I have over 20
years experience in both developer and
operations roles I have been solving the
real world problems associated would
give up today for over 10 years as
welcome to Train to share my knowledge
experience with you i have written and
presented courses on subjects such as
java programming and how to set at the
climax web server randolph KO has over
40 years experience with a focus on team
coaching and mentoring trading and
software architecture development he has
spent the last six years focused on
cloud architecture development and
training in Finland DevOps practitioner
course comprises 26 hours of e-learning
three hands on practice projects using
the Google cloud platform compute engine
three simulated test for self assessment
project mentoring sessions and global
teaching assistants GGA there will be
teaching assistants support from the
simply learn staff at any time during
the course and for the project queries
can also be submitted at help and
support on www.hsn Kalencom students can
connect with the staff using simply talk
and live chat options and that's about
it go ahead and begin DevOps
institutional course and get started
with the first lesson happy learning
[Music]